okay greetings in the wonderful name of
our Lord and Savior Jesus Christ with
you here is our brother Marcelo cheese
our video and Pastor Randy skating it's
uh nice having you here pastor we just
have a few questions that we are going
to address and pasta is going to clarify
on things that most of us don't
understand so Pastor the first question
is what are the primary uses of the
offering the primary uses of the
offering yes let's pray before we I try
to answer Father in Heaven grant me
wisdom from above that what I say may be
accurate in the light of your word in
Jesus name I pray amen the offering is
used for the administration of the local
church the tithe is forwarded to the
local conference but the offering is for
the management of the local church and
its business
let's go forward okay the next question
says can you personally give tithe to a
specific minister or strictly be
distributed to the conflict
if that is done we introduce the
principal found in judges every man did
that which was right in his own eyes the
established method is you return the
tithe to the church yes if every
individual member decides I'll give it
to this person that person or that
Ministry then the local church will
collapse and so my recommendation is and
this is the recommendation of the church
also return the tithe to the look now if
you are individually convicted by God on
some isolated occasion to fund that
Ministry or that Ministry I cannot argue
with that but the generally accepted
principle is return the tithe to the
church amen the second question is can
you forgo a strictly plant-based diet or
articles of it for health reasons can
you forego a strictly plant-based diet
yes I mean can you set it aside yes in
place of meat yes well you never set
aside the best for the better the best
is plant-based based on Eden in Genesis
chapter one and so you don't give up the
very yes in order to accommodate
something of a lower standard again I'm
not being judgmental I'm simply saying
God always desires the best of us amen
and the best is plan based because
spiritual growth is connected to
physical well-being and so the
physically the more physically fit you
are the more uh advantageous it is for
you to be spiritually fit as well amen
and so diet is not removed from
spirituality
third question how can one prepare for
the time of trouble that is just ahead
by being faithful to God today
you see because you may die tonight and
never see the time of trouble be
faithful to God today Luke 16 10 says he
that is faithful in that which is least
is faithful also in much be faithful to
God in the little things acquaint
yourselves with the word of God so that
you may know what to expect if God
chooses to allow you to live to that
time but in case he doesn't be ready to
meet him today and so progression for
the time of trouble is to be faithful to
God today to fill one's mind with the
the prophecy the Bible to know what is
coming down the pipe so to speak and
thus to be ready but I don't want to
encourage people to cast their minds
into the future the time of trouble is
coming in 10 years from now what shall I
do no today today a person who's
prepared today can face anything that
comes tomorrow
amen fourth question is how can one
study the Bible effectively one consider
the Bible effectively by selling the
Bible in a very disciplined and
organized way
the fight the fundamental purpose for
Bible study is to discover God's will
for your life not to win an argument or
conduct a Bible study what is God's will
for me today that's why I study the
Bible another reason for Bible study is
spiritual growth power to resist
temptation you study the Bible there's a
a very simple method I learned from
someone else you take a verse whether
it's John 3 16 and you ask yourself what
is the verse saying
what is the verse saying to me because
Bible study must first be individual
salvation is an individual matter mind
character and personality volume two
page 423 paragraph two alawite writes
the gospel deals with individuals and so
what is God saying to you through this
verse what's the verse saying what is it
saying to you what it is requiring of
you to do or to put away you see if it's
a sin put it away a duty perform it and
those are questions you ask as you study
individually I also urge people to try
to study the Bible in connection with
the writings of Eloy that deal with that
passage of the Bible for instance you
said in John go to the Desire of Ages
you're studying The Parables of Jesus
you go to thoughts on the bless all
Christ object lessons you do that so you
get some very very inspired commentary
on the word of God studying Daniel
Revelation you go to a great controversy
yes amen next question is
um what are the requirements to be in
courtship or can anyone decide to be in
courtship at any time well you can
decide to be in courtship at any time
that's what you want to do but
biblically from the standpoint of God on
the Christian Life a courtship is for
someone or persons considering marriage
courtship is not a recreational activity
it's a very serious business and so
courtship is for people considering
marriage and measure not measuring but
observing one another trying to learn
each other under the guidance of the
All-Seeing Eye of God Amen and by the
way courtship should not belong we're
assuming we have two fairly mature
people emotionally mature spiritually in
every other way and they have determined
how their Union can make them even more
effective in serving God how the union
could be advantageous to both of
themselves and to God's word if you
cannot see how you're glorify God don't
even take step one in coaching it must
be for the glory of God as Extreme as
that position may sound whether
therefore you eat or drink or Court
do also the glory of God and if more of
us consider the glory of God there might
be few marriages
amen amen
hearing a wedding ring a sin wearing a
wedding ring is not a sin if you're
convicted not to wear it and you wear it
then that's the same for you are you
following me it is not a doctrinal sin
but if God convicts you not to wear it
you don't need and you do simply to
submit to pressure or keep up with
custom then you've put yourself in
spiritual trouble but wearing a ring is
not a sin but let me say the most
important ring is not the one with your
finger the one around your heart amen
amen uh next question is how can you
describe a holy wedding which is
acceptable in the sight of God how can I
describe a holy wedding I attended a
wedding a few years ago I was a part of
it and there was a sermon before the
ceremony a couple of testimonies and
serious prayer because the couple wanted
to glorify God and so they made God the
centerpiece of the marriage ceremony I
had never seen that before not even in
my own marriage I hope my wife isn't
listening but they had a sermon they had
testimony they had prayer they had
singing they were determined to make God
the scent you see in most weddings it's
not all but most let me not be uh
bold to say all in most the centerpiece
of a wedding is the bridegroom the bride
you see what is she wearing how does she
live how did the Bridesmaids look that's
what people come to see not to see God
and I don't want to be judgmental that's
my experience and so a wedding should
deliberately focus on God because you
see Jesus Christ is the bridegroom the
church is the bride yes and so we should
try to make God a centerpiece of a
marriage ceremony and the scent of a
wedding ceremony and the centerpiece of
the marriage
you see weddings receive attention
marriages deserve I hope you understand
the same we spend money for our wedding
the last two hours but the marriage
itself that goes on for decades receives
very little attention yes yes
okay
um next question what does it what does
it matter on which day to wash it it
matters because God has already chosen
the day and it's his if you read Genesis
chapter 2 verses 1 to 3 thus the heavens
and the Earth were finished and all the
host of them and on the seventh day God
ended his work which he had made and he
rested on the seventh day from all his
work which he had made and God bless the
server's day and Sanctified it because
that in it five times the day is
identified it is God's day remember the
Sabbath day to keep it holy six days
shall thou labor and do all thy work but
the seventh day is the Sabbath of the
Lord thy God now if God has chosen the
day who am I to come and say it doesn't
matter what day God has told if God had
said pick a day now we have a different
story altogether God didn't say pickity
he picked the day and you decide to
choose to blame me or not you cannot
decide you see if you begin counting
seven days from Thursday you end up on
Wednesday as your seventh day are you
following me yes if you begin calling on
Tuesday your seven days one that
everyone can have his or her on Seventh
day God has chosen his is the creation
sample of the seventh day um
how do you overcome addiction addiction
we think of Psalm 119 verse 133 order my
steps in thy word and let not any
iniquity have dominion over me that's an
addiction let not any iniquity the word
of God now I'm not discounting
professional interventions psychiatric
intervention or medication I'm not I'm
saying for the Christian the chief
medication is the word of God Christ's
object lessons page 100 paragraph one if
study and obeyed the word of God works
in the heart subduing every Unholy
attribute now we don't believe it so
nothing happens but the word of God
Psalm 119 verse 9 where with All Shall
the young man cleanse his way or a woman
by taking him there to according to Thy
word verse 11 of the same chapter Thy
word have I hid in my heart that I might
not sit against thee John 15 3 Jesus
told the disciples now you clean through
the word which I have spoken to you the
the breaking of addiction principle one
get the word of God into you it is the
most powerful cleansing and again I am
not discounting professional
intervention that's fine make sure the
professional intervention is the
Christian background not secular
counseling Christian Counseling because
you because you become so right out of a
relationship with God and so yes the
word of God is the primary tool in NYC
is the primary agency in the
transformation of character amen amen
there is no sin God's word cannot
conquer if studied and obeyed
amen next question is uh what is a
christ-like character a christ-like
character is a character like Christ you
see it's very simple you think like
Christ you behave like Christ you act
like Christ it does not happen overnight
and you'll develop that character as you
study Christ second Corinthians 3 18 by
beholding we become changed you cannot
develop a Christian character by and not
study the Bible you cannot do that you
can develop a decent character not a
christ-like character decency is not
conversion even though a converted
person will be decent to develop a
character of Christ you have to study
the Life of Christ
mm-hmm and you have to go to the Bible
for that hmm the Bible has the power to
change you into his disability of Christ
the last question is
what circumstance best defines an
individual as ready to engage in a
marriage relation maturity
spiritual maturity not spiritual
Perfection spiritual maturity yes
um Financial maturity
emotional maturity
when God performed the first wedding
ceremony he put a man and a woman not a
boy and a girl are you following me he
put a man and a woman that tells you a
lot not a boy and a girl and so there
needs to be a level of maturity adults
get married biblically and not children
I hope that covers a broad field uh be
mature spiritually first psychologically
mentally emotionally because marriage is
more stressful than pictures of weddings
messages
I like to say marriage is reveal what
courtship conceals you see you think
you're marrying a a an archangel two
weeks into the marriage you realize this
man is Barabbas and you never recognized
it you need to be emotionally uh mature
you need to have discernment and that
comes from studying the word of God
counseling with spiritual leaders like
your pastor talking to your parents
particularly even if they're not
Christian parents they know you yes you
do these things you don't proceed on
your own wisdom because I am 18 I can do
what I want that's a recipe for disaster
you see count muscle you praying you
seek God and you measure your behavior
and the behavior of your expected one is
this relationship drawing me closer to
God am I spending more time with God I
am more rebellious than my parents since
I met this young man with this young
lady do I have less time for church if
these things are going on you're in the
wrong direction
so maturity first spiritual not
Perfection maturity
I'm ready to take on burdens of
responsibilities but fundamentally
you want that Union to glorify God
that's the Bedrock Cornerstone and if
you cannot see how don't move yes right
thank you that was our last question but
now uh for all the viewers faster maybe
you have a weight of encouragement to
the young people especially in the
Seventh Adventist Church they seem to be
this form of uh uh a form of godliness
so what is your address
oh yes yes so what is your advice to all
the views and everyone who is watching
that uh what are your last words to my
last words are these make the Bible your
guide and your rule of life and this
applies regardless of age yes you see
there is no hell for 16 year olds and
the health of 50 year olds all Sinners
go to hell all safe go to heaven and so
regardless of your age but since my
brother required me to talk to the young
people I'm talking to them let the word
of God Be Your guide you heard me say
earlier Psalm 119 verse 9 we're with
also the young man comes his ways by
taking his theater according to Thy word
verse 11 Thy word have I hid in my and
so make this the word of God your rule
your guide and stay in it regardless of
what you're doing if you're in
University study with the glory of God
in mind how can I discover God in math
or in physiology or in histology
whatever it is you seeking God in
everything you do and you live with the
Consciousness I am on this Earth for the
glory of God Isaiah 43 Verse 7 I have
created him for my glory no one is on
this Earth for his own purpose or her
own purpose it sounds extreme but
heavily thinking is Extreme when
compared to Earth rethinking you're on
this Earth for the glory of God not for
your own Glory seek God's glory in
everything you do and you cannot fail to
represent Jesus Christ all right thank
you very much you had the pasta himself
thank you very much for availing
yourself for this q a may God bless you
God bless you brother thank you okay and